welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of
everything you might have missed in the
trailer for she-hulk with tatiana
maslany playing jennifer walters hi
powered attorney cousin to bruce banner
and soon to be the face of a new trend
of athletic wear she-hulk is one of the
funniest and coolest characters in the
marvel comics fully self-aware of her
own bonkers existence while whipping
that sharp legal intellect at everyone
from the avengers to the tva and
sometimes in the offense of arrows but
never mind that cause i'm gonna go frame
by frame to break down all the easter
eggs you might have missed and let's get
started
i'm jennifer walters
i'm a normal lawyer
well
not that normal so we open on tatiana
maslany as jennifer walters doing yoga
in her neat ikea home one that you know
it's just gonna get wrecked when she
hulks out maslany earned praise for her
role on orphan black playing several
amazing distinct identities a skill that
will serve her well on this series when
she plays both jen and her larger than
life alter ego an ego that won't be
monstrous and aggro but brash and
confidence still in control in the
comics jen was bruce banner's cousin who
prosecutes criminals who end up trying
to kill her leaving it to bruce to give
her a blood transfusion that ends up
powering her up into she-hulk but unlike
bruce in the comics she reaches a stasis
with her hulked out form choosing to
stay green all of the time here as an
attorney she wears a plum colored shirt
the way bruce banner in the mcu often is
shown wearing purple hulk's classic
pants color but very briefly we see her
hulked out form wearing white purple and
black attire similar to her outfit in
the comics and i love it cross trainers
her athletic shape here is somewhat
inflated but not too much so keeping our
eyes focused on her personality i know
it feels a bit gross to be talking so
much about her forum but keep in mind
that is a conversation about she-hulk
whether you like it or not and these are
all freakish fantastical characters and
if you've been watching new rockstars
you know i've spent more time on this
channel epstep scene over the physiques
of hulk and thor all their gutters so
now that we have talked about it we can
put that to bed and move on and talk
about her hair because tatiana maslany
was given curls in this show which at
first i thought is that really just so
that she'd look more like mark ruffalo
but no it was added to contrast
she-hulk's wild mane of dark green hair
we focus on all these features but we do
not yet see the character's face which i
think is so smart for this teaser
because they're probably still working
on the vfx there and whenever you first
show a vfx constructed character
revealing the face is often where you
risk losing viewers in that uncanny
valley right this way it just keeps fans
guessing and lets fans know that this
isn't gonna shy away from the she-hulk
we know from the comics on to the next
clip these transformations are triggered
by anger and fear don't make me angry
you wouldn't like me when i'm angry
nice so mark ruffalo returns in this
series but we see him here in his smart
hulk form from avengers end game rockin
the hoodie gym shorts and bare feet that
those of us from florida call winter
chic meanwhile jen is wearing baggy
clothes clearly expecting to bulk out
here or what those of us from florida
who relocated to california called 2020
chic hmm
you know leave our homes so this must be
banner's gamma lab that he referred to
in end game when he explained how he got
this way 18 months in a gamma lab i put
the brains and the bra and together and
now look at me and i love this detail
you can tell this lab was designed for
powerful game of radiation because all
the walls appear to be carved into thick
stone maybe concrete lined with lead now
abomination meow blonsky tim roth will
return in this series after his crazy
cameo fighting wong and chung chi
actually the cell he returns to through
wong's portal looks a bit like hulk scam
a cell here maybe blonsky was being kept
in this lab as banner worked to depower
him now in in-game banner never went
into further detail as to how exactly he
reached the stasis that allowed him to
stay permanently in hulk form while
retaining his banner intellect but this
is exactly the type of balance that
she-hulk normally has so the mcu may be
using that twist from in-game to justify
why she-hulk is the way that she is now
this scene could be taking place after a
transfusion that would have briefly
caused jen to chaotically hulk out and
now bruce is trying to help her reach
that balance he has discovered with just
the right cocktail of game of radiation
or it could just be that there's
something in the banner family blood
that gets triggered by gamma radiation
this way notice how on his screens the
bottom one shows jen and her biostats
whereas the top one seems to be showing
his own so right now banner could be
calibrating the radiation to the level
that he used on himself notice here that
jen wears a helmet that seems to be
wired in from above this actually could
be how bruce irradiated himself with
gamma while leaving his mind unaffected
by using a helmet that blocks out the
gamma from making his brain stupid now
here at new rockstars our sharp wit and
keen eyes can cut through the web of
information out there to give you the
top-notch content you came here for but
to cut through food you need kamikoto
knives kamikoto makes great japanese
steel kitchen knives using traditional
techniques from japan their knives are
used by michelin star restaurants around
the world they only use premium steel
sourced from the mills in japan and each
kamikoto knife is individually inspected
after a 19 process which makes them so
confident in their knives that each one
comes with a lifetime guarantee each
knife comes in this beautiful ash wood
box that keeps the knife stored safely
and makes a kamikoto knife a great
looking gift they offer a wide range of
japanese steel knives from the eight and
a half inch slicing knife down to a five
inch blade better suited for smaller
fruits or veggies and cutting stuff in a
crowded elevator without stabbing your
neighbor i wouldn't recommend it but you
know options i grabbed a nakiri knife
and it feels incredible in my hand it
just looks really cool and it feels well
balanced and super functional it's got
me ready for dicing and chopping
kamikoto has an early black friday sale
going on and on top of their offers
kamikoto is offering our viewers an
extra 50 off any purchase with discount
code rockstars so head to kamikoto.com
rockstars banner says that these
transformations are triggered by anger
and fear which could also mean that
maybe his zen-like mastery over his
emotions played a pretty big role in his
successful fusion of his forms
ultimately we know that banner reverts
to his human form at some point after
the event of end game based on his arm
still in the sling as it was at the end
of end game when he meets with shanghi
katie wong and carol danvers in the shan
chipo's credit scene so maybe banner had
to return to human form in order to be
able to give blood to his cousin because
think about it as smart hulk no
transfusion needle would have been able
to penetrate his skin and maybe what we
see in chongqi was just him during that
temporary power down jen quotes bruce
banner's classic line you wouldn't like
me when i'm angry mr mcgee don't make me
angry
you wouldn't like me when i'm angry and
bruce is now in human form like he
appeared in that shanghai post credit
scene but something odd is going on here
bruce's arm is not in the sling as it
was in the chungchi scene his hair is
not nearly as gray and both he and jen
look like they're wearing late 70s or
early 80s attire specifically bill
bixby's attire as david banner in the
1978 incredible hulk series also you'll
notice the focus is soft like we're
watching this on an old tv set and yeah
it's pretty weird to see her break the
fourth wall and look directly into
camera to deliver the catchphrase it's
almost as if we are watching an episode
of one division are these two in a
reality warped by wanda maximoff during
the events of one division who knows how
far wanda's hex expanded at the end of
episode six hulk's gamma lab could be
near westview new jersey like a camp
lehigh in new jersey and maybe they got
caught in that tv reality war making
them look like ironically the 1978 hulk
tv show which the mcu has already
referenced specifically in the ed norton
film with the return address on the
package he sent to liv tyler referencing
david banner and the fact that they
sampled the music from that show
now if not a one division crossover this
could just be an example of how the
she-hulk series will playfully break the
fourth wall in its own way perhaps with
jen's imagination taking her to these
silly cutaways i mean the series is a
legal comedy something i imagine to be
in the vein of ali mcbeal which would
also engage in these fantastical
interludes and hey co-starred iron man
remember the hat when i used to be in
other things and that procedural tone is
i think the reason behind the new
she-hulk title logo which i gotta admit
i'm not a huge fan of i much prefer the
original one and has a city backdrop as
we often see in legal shows by the way
this is the city of los angeles i know
that light pollution and smog anywhere
suggesting this series might have the
snappier and more glamorous la vibe that
we haven't really seen in the mcu since
the iron man movies you'll also see that
glamour in the brief shot later in the
reel showing jen flashing some angelina
leg as she steps out of a car at a fancy
red carpet event but also while you
scrub through this reel there is one
totally inexplicable shot that seems to
show tatiana maslany's screaming as she
gets dragged into a cave this looks
horrifying something more out of moon
knight than she-hulk i would imagine but
maybe another representation of jen's
inner fantasies or inner fears as she
wrestles with her inner demons to
conquer her fear and master her outer
form could also be part of a fight with
the villain of this series titania mary
mcferrin played by jamila jamil as
someone who has always loved she-hulk's
sense of humor and the way she kind of
laughed at herself and was able to poke
fun at the marvel comics i'm just so
excited for this series and tatiana
maslany is gonna do such a good job as a
new leader the avengers perhaps or at
least just a brilliant legal mind to
debate the likes of the tva or the
living tribunal or whoever it's going to
prosecute peter parker get this woman in
the mcu right away to support this
channel check out one of our great merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at eavos
follow the new rockstars subscribe to
rockstars analysis and breakfast of
everything marvel thanks for watching
this is my seventh video i shot today
i'm so tired but we did it
[Music]
you